meanwhile people who defend themselves
against criminals get the maximum
possible sentence the government gets to
defend itself with bodyguards
politicians have tons of bodyguards you
pay for
Congress is so afraid of the people they
govern they built a wall around the
capitol this week
but you can't fight back and we began to
see this accelerate in 2020 during the
BLM riots so a BLM mob broke the gate
into Market Patricia McCloskey's
property in St Louis they were having
dinner all of a sudden the mob shows up
and so in response they did what you
would do if you were awake you grab your
Firearms you don't shoot anybody back
off those Firearms were lawfully owned
they were on their property as was the
mob
here's what it looked like
[Applause]
[Music]
remember that they were racist right a
group of Highly entitled children of
orthodontist showed up on their property
to threaten them and they said back off
so they're racists at the Washington
Post
and then of course the Soros back
prosecutor called Kim Gardner
charged them charged the class the
mccloskeys with crime not the mod the
mccloskeys for daring to defend
themselves their guns were seized
now the point of this of course is not
to make anybody safer just the opposite
and St Louis has not become safer it's
become much more dangerous under Kim
Gardner the city has experienced its
highest murder rate in decades
so Public Safety is not the point the
point is disarming you so you can't
defend yourself against their plans for
you
now thankfully Mark McCloskey and his
wife were pardoned
these outrageous charges by the governor
of the state thank God Mark McCluskey is
still around he joins us now Mark
Pulaski thank you so much for coming on
that your story was so significant
because it seemed like the beginning of
a trend where political prosecutors
send the message that you're not allowed
to defend yourself no matter how crazy
and chaotic and dangerous the country
becomes don't take up arms to defend
your property your family your own life
and I think it's fair to say it was the
beginning of a trend no
well it was and you know this is not
accidental and it's not a result of
inadvertence or incompetence what's our
right to defend ourselves it's a
god-given right it's a basic human right
well the powers that be that want to
destroy our government want to destroy
our freedoms and want to destroy our
culture they can't tolerate the concept
of there being a power greater than
government they have to do away with
your god-given rights all your rights
and let's leave you with nothing but
government granted privileges that can
be revoked at a moment's notice I mean
that's exactly what's going on
we've got it we've got a vice president
of the United States who encouraged the
riots so the riots are proper they
should continue bailed people out of
jail so they can Riot the next day we
got a government that encourages crime
and then discourages law enforcement by
defunding the police and these George
Soros prosecutors like I have here in St
Louis and then what do the people do if
there's rampant crime and the police
won't enforce the law and the
prosecutors won't prosecute the
criminals people have to defend
themselves so then what that same
government then criminalizes
self-defense and throws you in jail now
you know it wasn't cheap to defend
ourselves and then to add insult to
injury our bar association required us
to do a hundred hours each of pro bono
Legal Services uh so that's 200 hours of
our time that's about a 150 000 Buck
fine right there but we can we can
handle that but think about that poor
George Allen Kelly down in Texas 73 year
old man with a million dollar bond for
doing nothing more than defending
himself the whole purpose of all this is
to strip our rights away strip away our
god-given freedoms and and give absolute
control to the government criminalize
criminalize self-defense and and glorify
the government
yeah so they start a crime wave and then
demand you give up your guns yeah no no
thanks no thanks Mark Pulaski great to
see you thank you so much
thank you subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight